qu'est ce que j'aimerais que daniel
passe la même photo
qu'est ce que vous pensez mais non
excusez moi qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais moi je dis que c'est une honte son
principe mais s'il ya des gens qui
veulent l'acheter c'est là on est limite
à la perversité vous avez vu le message
de faire
des trucs érotique
c'est une fille qui assume totalement ce
qu'elle est elle dit qu'elle aime
l'argent et elle essaie de se
débrouiller seuls pour en gagner voilà l
attend pas après un homme à l attend pas
elle attend après personne tu ne savais
pas comment tout ça parce que s est pas
un homme qui lui donne le torrent tu te
sais qu'elle est qu elle avoue qu'elle
n'a pas son argent à bras un homme tu
peux pas ça mais
pas pascal a vendu l'autre son band on
se charge lorsque
elle a su avant son cours sur internet
elle vend son corps sur internet
c'est une avancée
l'autre sont bons qu'à se débrouille
tout seul ses mélanges savants son corps
comme le petit benjamin leyre facile ils
font ça après c'est légal suivant du
canon j'ai fait des matches de foot avec
ça c'est sûr c'est pas potable c'est
bien j'ai des cas se débrouille toute
seule chez elle elle l'avait après qu'il
voudra non l' anneau intéressant donc
pages il ira dîner d'après moi j'suis
d'accord avec elle fait ce qu'elle veut
et si elle est gogo suffisamment
stupides pour aller à la limite tant
mieux pour elle après elle est quand
même dans un système un peu pervers
monsieur parce que on a l'impression que
les influenceurs aujourd'hui elles sont
bout d'un système et font des
brainstormings matin disant mais qu'est
ce que je vais pouvoir faire de bien
choquant de bien bizarre de bien tordu
pour faire le buzz et pour qu'on puisse
parler de moi il faut se rappeler que
pendant la première crise du kobe le
premier confinement elle avait fait 1-1
stalheim où elle avait demandé à ce
qu'ils aient beaucoup de de vue et elle
prenait elle menaçait de se suicider
elle avait pris des cachets au fur et à
mesure des vues
10000 vue elle était tombée genre
malaise comme si elle allait elle allait
mourir donc il ya quand même un rapport
malgré tout je trouve qui est très
malsain on avait moi ça me fait peur
après appel généralités à cuba tout
comme ça c'est simple et non mais c'est
long
est ce que tu veux plus loin moi je
trouve que kelly est indéfendable là
dessus et moi si cette personne rubini
carats étaient là je dirais que je suis
fier d'inviter de maintien abba génial
je dirais alors que ce qu'elle fait
profondément scandaleux dire et 1500
pour l'eau du bain écarté du foot mais
on a bien devant
[Rires]
mais c'est une super idée devant l'autre
son mari
encore ce n'est pas des conneries que je
peux juste dire un truc après le chiffre
parce que c'est grave que tu viens de
dire je dis que c'est du foutage de
gueule des vidéos 50 euros à des fans
pour avoir un coucou mais j'ai jalal
quand vous tombez bien expliqué
alors d'accord auquel alors qu'elle
vienne me dire qu'elle donne ça une
association de fait en tant que toi
comme
celle de la diffamation qui avait dopé
les questions
est un génie c'est pas pareil de vendre
les mineurs ou de dédicaces et de vendre
des de l'eau de son bain ou des photos
de fonctions dès le début parce qu'on
l'a vue je suis désolé c'est à dire
quelque chose de choquant mais la
frontière que la prostitution elle est
très très minces a dû à un reportage ya
pas longtemps dans sept à huit là dessus
le problème c'est que l'argent il est
tellement facile qu'en face il ya des
gens qui parlent qui vous font des
demandes de plus en plus osés toutes ces
femmes elles se fixent des limites et à
jour ça va mais grimpent à 6 ben moi je
veux payer 1000 euros chez avec toi la
prostituée 3 dimanche qu'on trouve ça
mais non mais banalisée ça et dire à
tous les jeunes filles comme lieu de
faire un travail normal elles peuvent se
prostituer gagné dix vingt trente mille
euros par mois oui ça me choque c'est
même à mon père a encore une fois